gráfica el conjunto solución de este
sistema de desigualdades y aquí tengo
dos desigualdades
entonces para encontrar el conjunto
solución de este sistema desigualdades
simultáneamente lo que voy a hacer es
graficar cada una de estas desigualdades
y ver en qué región del plano cartesiano
se intersectan los dos conjuntos
solución justo en donde se intersectan
mis dos soluciones va a ser mi respuesta
así que bueno primero déjenme hacer un
plano cartesiano aquí tengo el eje de
las x por acá tengo el eje de leyes y
bueno lo primero que voy a hacer es
fijarme en mi primera desigualdad que
dice james tiene que ser más grande que
x menos 8 y bueno para graficar esta
desigualdad lo primero que voy a hacer
es fijarme en mi recta frontera o en mi
recta límite de esta desigualdad que es
la recta de igual a x menos 8 y la x
menos 8 corta el eje de las 10 en menos
8 y ordenada en origen es menos 8 así
que voy a bajar 1
3 4 5 6 7 8 por aquí debe de pasar esta
recta y bueno tenemos en esta recta
frontera una pendiente de 1 por lo tanto
por cada uno que yo suba en x voy a
caminar 1 en bien entonces vamos a
dibujarlo aquí sin pendientes de 1
tenemos que pasar en x igual a 8 date
cuenta que si nosotros subimos 8 tenemos
que caminar 8 hacia la derecha entonces
estamos en este punto de aquí y ya te
puedes imaginar la recta ahora antes de
dibujarla date cuenta que mi solución no
incluye a esta recta por lo tanto tiene
que ser una recta punteada esta es mi
recta límite sin embargo mi desigualdad
dice que ya debe de ser mayor estricto
que x menos 8 por lo tanto no toca o no
incluye a esta recta y bueno para poner
esto va a ser una línea punteada desde
aquí entonces déjenme borrar esto y
déjame ponerla mejor con otro color con
color verde en un color verde me voy a
tomar esta recta que estoy dibujando
justo aquí
es punteada porque no le incluye mi
solución y no voy a tomar las guías que
sean más grandes que x menos 8 por lo
tanto lo que queremos es todos los
puntos que estén arriba de esta recta
todos los puntos cuya coordenada en
james sea más grande que esta recta y
son todos estos de aquí así que déjame
aquí dibujar el conjunto solución de
esta desigualdad de mi primer
desigualdad y bueno vamos a ver si
realmente gráfica moss la región
correcta vamos a tomarnos el origen para
verificar cuando x es 0 y lleva de 0
entonces en este punto estaríamos
diciendo que es 0 es más grande que 0
menos 8 es decir que 0 es más grande que
menos 8 lo cual es cierto por lo tanto
parece ser que si tomamos la región
correcta y ahora si nos tomamos un punto
que no esté en esta región se me ocurre
pensar en el punto 10 0 entonces diría
que cero es más grande que 10 menos 80
es más grande que 10 menos 8 esto quiere
decir que 0 es más grande que 2 y eso no
es cierto por lo tanto estamos en la
región correcta hasta aquí vamos bien ya
ver si vamos a fijarnos en nuestra
siguiente desigualdad mi segunda
desigualdad me dice que
es menor que 5 - x por lo tanto primero
vamos a fijarnos en nuestra recta
frontera que es y es igual a 5 - x la
cual corta el eje de la 10 en que igual
a 5 es decir estamos justo aquí esto es
no ordenada al origen y tenemos una
pendiente de menos 1 date cuenta que
esto es lo mismo que poner y es igual a
menos 1 por x + 5 entonces si nosotros
bajamos 5 en esta recta tenemos que
caminar 5 a la derecha esto es lo que
quiere decir una pendiente de menos 1
por cada unidad que bajemos vamos a
caminar esa misma unidad a la derecha
entonces pasamos por aquí y ya tenemos a
nuestra recta en la cual recuerda que no
hay que dibujar la sólida porque fíjate
que también tenemos una desigualdad
estricta por lo tanto tenemos que
dibujar también una recta punteada y lo
que nos dicen es que jett debe ser menor
que esta recta entonces nos vamos a
tomar todos los puntos que tengan una
coordenada en menor a esta recta y si te
das cuenta todos los puntos que cumplan
esa propiedad son los puntos que deben
estar abajo de esta recta así que
déjenme colorear todos
abajo de esta recta de este color morado
morado rosa entonces dejen de poner todo
esto y ahorita vamos a verificar que en
efecto sea toda esta es la solución de
nuestra segunda desigualdad y bueno
vamos a ver si sí vamos a ver con un
punto que esté adentro de esta región el
punto 0 0 0 en x y 0 njei me quedaría
que 0 es más chico que 5 y esto es
cierto por lo tanto ahora vamos a
tomarnos un punto que no esté en esta
región me voy a tomar el punto 0 10 10
tiene que ser menor que 5 menos cero y
eso no es cierto por lo tanto no está en
mi región perfecto entonces hasta aquí
vamos bien y ahora para juntar estas dos
regiones porque yo lo que quiero es el
conjunto solución de este sistema de
desigualdades lo que me tengo que fijar
es en la región en la cual se
intersectan mis dos soluciones o dicho
de otra manera para los cuates aquella
región en la cual está coloreada de dos
colores que si te das cuenta es
justamente esta de aquí ni conjunto
solución de una manera gráfica de este
sistema de ecuaciones es todo esto que
estoy pintando justo ahorita
a punto de esta región cumple
simultáneamente que es mayor que x menos
8 pero su vez ya es menor que 5 - x y
ojo no olvidemos que las fronteras no
están incluidas